les week-ends nature ça continue tout le
mois d'octobre et les sites des espaces
naturels sensibles vous attendent avec
les équipes sur place pour vous faire
découvrir la nature comme vous ne l'avez
jamais vu dans la région nord le 19 et
23 octobre sans doni domaine fleurier
rencontre avec un apiculteur et
découverte d'espèces indigènes et
endémiques de l'île une surprise
attendra les visiteurs en fin de matinée
un indice cric et crac et le 30 octobre
chemin des anglais découverte d'un joyau
inscrit au patrimoine mondial de
l'humanité
la forêt sèche de la réunion le 20
octobre ste marie piton fougères
immersion dans une des plus remarquables
forêts primaires de l'île découverte des
reliefs de la réunion le 22 octobre sans
denis boulevard de la providence la
forêt vue d'en ho immersion dans la
canopée
venez visiter un arbre avec andy sim une
visite ouverte aux personnes porteuses
de handicap dans l'ouest sans le
mascarin jardin botanique les 18 le vin
le 22 le 23 et le 25 octobre
visite guidée sur les légumineuses
toxiques envahissant soir qualifié à
tort de mauvaises herbes mais également
découverte des légumineuses comestibles
un parcours adapté aux personnes
porteuses de handicap et beaucoup
d'autres choses encore à découvrir sans
gilles les bains réserve naturelle
marine les 20 21 22 et 23 octobre des
visites guidées sous-marine à la
découverte des écosystèmes récifaux sont
proposés avec des visites guidées sur le
lagon à 100 le pointe au sel le 23
octobre visite et découverte du site de
la pointe au sel et des salines
découverte du sel des ombres à travers
l'exposition temporaire du musée dans le
sud sentier de la roche merveilleuse à
redécouvrir le 29 octobre à san jose la
fluence juin à la rivière l'on joint au
cap blanc les 21 et 25 octobre
possibilité également de vous balader
dans la nature au tampon le 23 octobre à
notre dame de la paix des ateliers de
découverte de
apiculture des dégustations sur ce site
la forêt de sainte thérèse le 29 octobre
c'est une immersion dans un patrimoine
naturel remarquable ouvert pour la
première fois au public qui vous est
proposé dans l'est les 19 21 le 30
saint-andré forêt de dioré vous attend
avec une initiation à l'artisanat le
tressage de vacoa les 19 et 22 octobre
centre aux forêts bois blancs ou la
forêt de bois de couleurs et ses
ateliers de découverte idd 19 22 et 26
octobre ainsi que le 30 octobre sans
benoit forêt et dan liberia ce sont des
visites guidées de la flore et des
orchidées d'une forêt humide de moyenne
altitude qui vous sera proposé
salazie elle moore ce sera le 20 octobre
à la plaine des palmistes rendez vous au
sentier de l'école normale
le 22 octobre et pour la forêt de sens
marguerite les 23 et 29 octobre
découverte de la pépinière et des
ateliers de replantation d'espèces
indigènes
à vos baskets pour toutes ces visites en
seul numéro le 02 62 97 59 59 de
retrouver le programme complet sur le
www.cglpl.fr et sur le www.cn.ca
4 point fr slash nature